hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Rick and Morty's season 3
episode 5 the were leaderly conspiracy
yeah Rick and jerry episode so I'm gonna
go a little too deep and point out all
the fun details that the writers and
animators snuck in here and let's just
jump right into it starting with the
opening images so this episode begins
with the depressing montage of Jerry in
his bachelor pad and notice how he
stares reflectively at this frozen pie
as it slowly rotates in the microwave
now I'm gonna overanalyze the [ __ ] out
of this image kind of what we do here
deal with it I think this shot is
suggesting that Jerry feels a bit like
this pie just spinning in place and not
visibly changing stuck in a mundane
routine cycle that he can't break out of
now this episode is titled the were
leaderly conspiracy referring to the
were leaderly roller coaster that jerry
and rick go on later and rickles gets
assassinated on but the writers said
that this entire episode is structured
to mirror jerry and rick turning on each
other to these sudden turns of the were
leaderly and that turning motif starts
with this opening image jerry is
spinning in place until Rick arrives and
spins him off the rails from there Rick
turns Jerry's expectations confessing
that he's taking him out to appease
Morty not because they needed him on an
adventure or two as Jerry expects them
to dump them in space later Jerry turns
on Rick suggesting to go on the world
literally with him so that his assassins
can kill him but then Rick turns again
agreeing that he was partially
responsible for Jerry and Beth's
marriage falling apart and that causes
Jerry to turn back trying to save Rick
then when Jerry confesses Rick turns on
him again confessing his true reason for
hating him that he's a predator posing
as prey in order to lure in people with
his patheticness and then later after
enjoying rick's dumb docile state Jerry
tries to save him by attacking rosada
Groupon so really this entire episode is
thematically an emotional roller coaster
that allows these two competing
patriarchs of the Smith household to
come to terms with each other okay back
in Jerry's bachelor pad the way Rick
bursts in and pulls Jerry out of bed is
a direct call back to the very first
scene of the first episode of the series
and let's look back at all the other
ways this episode calls back past
episodes
okay so Jerry has this Titanic poster
over his bed that's a nod to the episode
Rick see business when both he and Beth
went on that stupid Titanic experience
later when summer and Beth argue you
see the interdimensional cable box in
the background of course that's from the
episode rixty minutes and in the
driveway in front of the house notice
the cracks forming the perimeter around
the property
this was also visible in past episodes
this season it's also from risky
business remember when they teleported
the house to another dimension and
brought it back without Jerry and Beth
noticing then there's Ethan summers old
boyfriend he shows up this episode
remember we saw him in season one's
anatomy park he was angry that summer
wasn't responding to his text and the
character Jacob got him to realize it's
because of a traumatic experience it
made me feel like a girl and that whole
idea of uncertainty of her sexual
identity kind of also applies to Jerry
this episode he confesses that he always
wanted to know what it felt like to have
a vagina which also might connect to his
past struggle over his love for sleepy
Gary in total Rick Hall then there's the
mailman from M Night simoleons he says
that briefly before he gets crushed when
Morty turns a mailbox into a giant Alex
and in the background of the resort bar
there's the alien from the blips and
shits arcade and Morty night run now the
main setting of this episode is this
super wealthy resort with an immortality
filled with no death disease or
dismemberment and this sounds like it
could be influenced by the movie Elysium
that's the Neill Blomkamp movie about
the one-percenters on the luxurious
Space Station with perfect health and as
always there were a bunch of other
cinematic influences on this episode so
let's go through all these references in
a breakdown segment that this channel
calls under the influence so also at
this resort is a super obese alien
stuffing his face this looks a lot like
the character from Monty Python's the
meaning of life who eats himself to
death and explodes and of course there's
the alien with the chin that looks like
Jeff Goldblum yo what's up Big Chill now
Rick is referencing the 80s go blue
movies The Big Chill in the fly and in
the fly Goldblum went into a telepods
and came out on the other side with his
DNA having mixed with a fly turning them
into a monster now the other storyline
this episode follows summer using Rick's
device the more Pfizer EXCI this seems
like Rick's version of the shrink
machine from Honey I Shrunk the Kids or
to be more specific the sequel honey I
blew up the kids this episode actually
ends similar to that movie with the
mother also growing to a gigantic size
and calming down the giant angry kid
here the writers use this device to
literally blow up summers body issues
later in the episode Beth says this
line right before she Clive Barker
herself by Barker made the movie
Hellraiser which features these bloody
skinless creatures which are definitely
an influence on the giant inside out
summer now the were leaderly
rollercoaster has the same design as the
machine from the Jodie Foster movie
contact in that movie it opened up a
wormhole to the other side of the galaxy
and actually that trippy journey that
she goes on seems to be an influence on
the look of Jerry's cosmic trip also the
character risotto Groupon says this
about Rick My Kingdom was usurped by
force with weapons and technology
supplied by your father-in-law this
actually sounds a lot like the origin
story of Tony Stark and the first iron
man remember he was attacked and
kidnapped using his own company's
weapons this is actually the second time
this season that Rick has been loosely
compared to Stark remember the suit up
and escape sequence and picker Rick was
definitely an homage to Iron Man and
then Rick says this line later after he
gets tranquilized Cookies avatar I just
love the idea that the dumbest version
of Rick is basically Jerry he loves
these overrated James Cameron movies
like Avatar Titanic he just thinks
they're too long finally the design of
the smooth leg runners mouth seems to be
influenced on the look of the predator
from the predator movies and the
demagogue and from stranger things
actually I like how this creature has
this scrotum like organ that smacks
cherry in his face the animators of Rick
and Morty always sneak in these gross
dumb sexual images so let's quickly run
through a couple of the others in a very
mature segment that we're going to call
jokes so of course when we see Rick's
x-ray showing all of his cybernetic
implants they made sure to include the
outline of its balls and even though
this isn't technically a dick joke as I
said Jerry mentioned this episode that
he wanted to know what it was like to
have a vagina and actually right before
he confesses this in the bathroom the
faucets are shaped like vaginas and is
probably why it was on his mind and of
course there is a ton of sexual imagery
during this trippy cosmic apotheosis
montage which begins with Jerry naked
and his genitals blurred out actually
this whole montage is visually
fascinating to look at it seems like it
may be influenced by movies like 2001 a
Space Odyssey and the goodbye moon man
sequence from Morty Knight run also it
reminded me a lot of the
interdimensional travel sequence from
Doctor Strange which coincidentally Dan
Harmon actually collaborated on No
a segment where you could like look more
closely at all this oh wait there is
zooming enhance okay so this is all
loaded with spiritual imagery there are
these good and evil figures that look
like they were taken out of that
existential film the Seventh Seal but
there are also pagan figures like the
Baphomet that's the bigger that has the
goat head it's an occult figure an
object of satanic worship behind them is
the all-seeing eye or the Eye of
Providence that's the religious /
Freemason symbol it's on the Great Seal
of the United States pictured on the
back of the one dollar bill a lot of
conspiracy theorists have also linked it
with the Illuminati which could be
connected to all the triangles that also
appear during the sequence really I
don't know what they're talking about
they're also these really creepy images
of Jerry as a gazelle and Rick is a lion
hunting them and are cut with this snuff
film footage on projector celluloid of
Rick and Jerry doing some really
inappropriate stuff finally the three of
them here are lying on a giant
Triskelion symbol which has a ton of
meanings of different cultures but it's
associated with the holy trinity in the
british isles now by the way the game
pocket Morty's has been updated to
include a lot of these characters in
this episode including spiritual leader
Rick Victorian Jerry Victorian Rick
risotto group on inside out Beth inside
out summer
Janu P bloopers and master Morty okay
real quick I'm gonna run through a few
other interesting things that I noticed
in this episode the darkest moment was
when the immortality field drops and
this alien kid accidentally kills his
sister and yeah this is really messed up
but it actually connects to a theme of
this whole series introduced back in the
first episode violence is real remember
Rick handed Morty that gun to shoot at
the gronckle Knights telling them that
they weren't real and then Morty shot
one and he bled to death
so the deaths that we see on the show
are all horrifying and tragic so I'm
glad they keep up with this consistently
also this is the detail of Beth making
art out of horse hooves and I like how
this is an example of Beth's arc
throughout this episode notice how later
rick says this about her what do you
think had more taken from them when you
shot 20 cc's of liquid dream killer into
my daughter she was Rick's daughter
Jerry she had options so Rick is
pointing out how Beth's career as a
horse surgeon was connected to her
settling for Jerry limiting herself from
a more creative life and now we see Beth
using materials from her day job to do
something more creative so as we saw in
pickle Rick Beth was starting to act
more like her father
which is something Morty straight-up
calls out this episode this are
is another form of Beth trying to make
something more interesting and kind of
creepy out of her everyday life just
like her father would and real quick I
like how when Rick uses his cybernetic
parts against risotto group on this
massive lip and just takes a form of a
little suction cup thing it actually
kind of reminds me of when Rick used
this make up the leg trick and get
schwifty
also notice how when Rick's left eye is
covered it screws with his depth
perception so he struggles to grab the
gun and that brings us to the post
credit scene with these three little
guys from the more Pfizer customer
support which is one my favorite jokes
this episode now if you look closely the
graffiti on the walls behind them shows
the words like tits and pansy and chili
dog but there's also another also unites
really I don't get what the fuss is
about this hail Hydra they also point
out a horribly mutated ethan who Morty
presumably used the more Pfizer on
earlier now it's interesting to see
Morty becomes such a no-nonsense badass
this season
in fact this could be the start of his
transformation into evil Morty if you
believe in that theory that all of the
events that were seeing over this series
are actually leading up to that moment
in the season one finale where evil
Morty was introduced also another
question about this what does this mean
for the new Anatomy park that Rick built
inside Ethan's body did it get destroyed
with all these mutations remember this
might not be the exact same Ethan that
Ethan was presumably Cronenberg back in
that c-137 dimension so unless the Rick
of this universe also had built an
Anatomy Park inside this Ethan the park
was probably long gone anyway do you
think Jerry can ever win over Rick and
win back his family and is Morty now the
most mature character on this show keep
this conversation going in the comments
below you can tweet me your thoughts at
EA boss or two new rock stars at new
rockstars share this video and subscribe
to our channel for more Rick and Morty
content and if you are a big fan of us
you can contribute to us on patreon big
thanks to all of our current donors
especially math you solve us alright
thanks for watching and see you next
week bye